yeah Sean how are you good Dave how are
you better than a freak with you you too
how can we help yes
actually a good if he deserves all right
this is a perfect question for you both
you guys I started trading in stocks in
2016 as a side cake I'm a biomedical
engineer but I do I love the math part
is Fox
welcome to real estate and my question
was actually and I got introduced to
program late so I would buy a stock like
that
two dollars it would go down to like a
dollar eighty initially our tenants that
I wouldn't and then I would sell it at
for making you know doubling my money in
a few weeks
but then I noticed that the debt was
kind of influencing my decision because
I was calculating my debt and I was like
okay this is an interest of 10% is
guaranteed this is not and I would panic
because I was like okay what happens to
go to two again and I lose my you know
lose my profit so now that stock is like
$45 so I would have made lots of money
at needless to say if I just held on to
it how do i psychologically get over
those kind of things and I've know I've
noticed that getting rid of the debt has
done a lot of that and so and also I
wanted to know what percent as far as my
budgeting and I've been on a tear
market-wise since I haven't paid
attention to the debt because I don't
have any debt anymore so I've been able
to just look at the business and so I've
done a lot better but also what
percentage of July budget it as a fun
because you said not to do single stocks
but I do as a side job what would you
reckon and I still fully fund my raw but
well what percentage of my income would
you recommend playing single stocks
that's left side gig didn't sound I'm
saying I don't fund made sense sorry
well I and I would not I mean I would
not recommend that you trade single
stocks as a side game if you want to do
it as a hobby because you enjoy the math
and feel with it the amount of money
that you spend on it would be the amount
of money that you'd be willing to spend
on entertainment when you lose it Oh
even though I have a like a track record
of success so put in my
enter 2 News said the guy right before
he loses all of it right 78 the
statistics are 78 percent of the day
traders lose money
oh it's more small tray you mean like
the state really mean by selling it look
in the same day usually have to tell
that's people screwing around with the
program that you're screwing around with
where you think that you have more
information more insight and better math
skills than the guys running a fifty
billion dollar mutual fund oh they're
gonna kick your butt every time dude
you're not gonna win this and so
whatever amount of money you want to
lose is the amount of money you play
this sounds like talking to a guy who
thinks he's gonna win at poker I'm going
to Vegas and pokers my side gig and how
much money are you willing to put up for
poker our slot machines or the whatever
the amount of money you're willing to
lose for the entertainment value of your
hobby and that's it because that's all
it can be and if you don't if you're not
real careful your confidence in your own
abilities are going to cause you to lose
a lot of money because you are playing
it you're playing a game of Russian
Roulette here and it is just a matter of
time before you get your teeth kicked in
on this and I think yeah being a
biomedical engineer you're gonna be
smarter than average Joe and that may
prop up your entry level success but
like you say that the other side of that
fulcrum man the more weight you put on
live into that teeter totter eventually
it's the same thing I mean you know it's
the guy that says I'm really good at
poker enough won the last hundred hands
and so I've got poker figured out hmm
you know to which everyone has the sly
grin on their face - this guy's getting
ready to get his teeth kicked and you
know it's just a matter of time and so
you you are going to lose on that it's
not the game is not designed that way
and so but again I don't mind if you
play it and I understand the math and
intrigue on it I'm a math nerd myself
and so I understand the draw to that I
understand the draw to counting cards I
understand that but I don't do either
one because I know how my brain works
and I if I started winning I would start
thinking that I'm a I'm a big bad boy
and I can play in a game that I
we don't need to be laying in and that's
what you're that's what's gonna happen
so be careful there please please you
called mast so you got an